but we have important news tonight on mr
super patriot himself mr higher honor
jim comey
today he appeared in front of the senate
judiciary committee earlier today
he doubled down on the deep state and
their lies about the steele dossier
actually trying to claim uh he was
hardly even involved in the russia
investigation at all
he signed three of the four fisa
warrants
which were based on the dirty russian
dossier
that we now know christopher steele used
a russian operative that the fbi had
known about for 10 years
here's some of his garbage from earlier
today
how is it possible that the system
gathers so much exculpatory information
this internet rumor according to cia
that the actual interview of the
subsource disavows the reliability
document that the actual subsource was
expected russian spy
how could all that happen and not get up
to you
the director of the fbi of one of the
most important investigations
in the history of the fbi how is that
possible
i can only speculate because it didn't
mr comey with all due respect
you don't seem to know anything
about an investigation that you ran this
investigation of the president was
corrupt the fbi and the department of
justice were politicized and weaponized
and in my opinion there are only two
possibilities
that you were deliberately corrupt or
woefully incompetent
and i don't believe you were incompetent
i
agree with senator cruz now even worse
is comey's apparent selective amnesia
all throughout today's questioning
because
the disgraced fbi director repeatedly
claimed he couldn't remember
any specifics about crossfire hurricane
or the dirty dossier
or the fisa process at all now for
example
comey couldn't say whether the dossier
was essential to getting
the warrant to spy on carter page and
the president
despite comey himself he signed three of
those fisa applications
now the word at the top of a fisa
application is
verified right at the top he signed
three of the four he put his signatures
on something that he said and he
testified to was verified before
court and by the way comey couldn't even
say if he was briefed at all about the
red flags
as it relates to steele's work with his
primary sub source
known to the fbi for over a decade as a
russian connected uh
spy and he said he didn't know whether
page was a source for the cia
and despite undeniable evidence to the
contrary
he couldn't answer even the most basic
questions about whether
fbi lawyer kevin kleinsmith altered
evidence which kleinsmith already pled
guilty to
and he couldn't even say who prepared
the applications to begin with
he doesn't even remember being briefed
about by bruce ohr
he doesn't remember anything in terms of
the interviews about the sub source
well that happened in january of 2017.
here's a whole small sample of mr higher
honor
uh let's say going low take a look
in october when the warrant was
submitted
the application was submitted
what effort had been made to verify the
dossier in october
i don't know specifically so in october
it's clear mr comey there was no effort
to verify the dossier before it was
given to the court do you agree with
that
i don't know the answer i don't remember
learning anything additional about
steele sources not that i recall no i
don't remember
or ever were you aware that in december
2016
the cia cia tells the fbi
they characterized the dossier as
internet rumor
i don't recall being informed of that
by the way we're about to cross-check
every other past statement mr comey's
ever made
and does comey actually expect anybody
to believe that the biggest abuse of
power corruption scandal happened inside
his fbi and he knew nothing about the
this the entire time but he remembered
every single second that he ever spent
as it relates to donald trump that he
was the guy that
pushed uh let's see the dirty dossier
you know
the now infamous intelligence community
assessment that was released in early
2017
and comey who is the one that who
briefed president trump that it was
salacious and unverified even though in
october
months earlier he claimed and signed a
document that said it was verified
so let's be clear nothing he said today
exonerates him and by the way just like
rod rosenstein and sally yates
knowing what they now know now they
wouldn't have signed the fisa warrant
well jim comey today said well knowing
what i know now i wouldn't have signed
the three fisa applications
and by the way that's not all because
tonight we're even learning more about
the extent of the deep state's cover-up
because according to a new
declassification from the director of
national intelligence
john ratcliffe at the request of lindsey
graham
barack obama himself was briefed by
then-cia director brennan about a
russian intelligence analysis claiming
that hillary clinton was drumming up
the russia collusion hoax in an attempt
to vilify then-candidate trump to
distract
from let's see those subpoenaed emails
she was deleting in the use of bleach
bit and the use of hammers and the
removal of sim
cards now the deep state is taking any
responsibility they're going to take it
for that misconduct
or they're doing the opposite just look
at for example
mueller pitbull andrew weissman telling
cbs that he wiped bones from the special
counsel's office
a big deal because uh everything was
backed up
really andrew well why were all the
phones
uh well put in there in the first place
anyway also tonight some democrats are
still playing petty politics by refusing
to meet with supreme court nominee judge
amy coney barrett
including chuckie schumer as she's
meeting with the
decent senators on capitol hill and by
the way hearings are set to start
october 12th putting the confirmation
vote at the end of the month
and there's not really anything
democrats can do to stop it here with
the reaction
senator uh lindsey graham he's with the
senate judiciary committee
so now you have sally yates rod
rosenstein and jim
comey who remembers nothing about the
fisa application the dossier
uh the sub source but he remembers every
second with donald trump
do you believe him because i do not all
i can say is he has a convenient memory
he remembers what is damning to trump
and when something is helpful to trump
it's like sergeant schultz was in charge
of the fbi i see nothing i hear nothing
i know nothing
it's hard to believe that the director
of the fbi
in charge of a investigation of a
sitting president
wasn't told oh by the way the sub-source
who prepared the dossier
we think is a russian agent back to
2009.
it's hard to believe they didn't tell
the director of the fbi
the sub source tells us that the dossier
is
bar talk not reliable take it with a
grain of salt
it's hard to believe that they don't
tell the fbi director the cia
has warned us that the dossier prepared
by christopher steele
and a suspected russian spy is all
internet rumor
so here's comey's problem if one person
can come forward
and say i briefed the director about the
problems with the subsource
i told the director that the cia was
worried about the reliability of the
dossier then he is in big time
trouble uh okay do you believe
him that he signed something where he
claims it's verified
and that he had no idea that if it was
verified
wouldn't that be a dereliction of duty
doesn't that mean he still committed
fraud on the court and
when he did find out the truth doesn't
the law require that he go back to that
court and inform that
court he signed something that wasn't
verified
yeah he's yet to tell the court i
apologize but what he said today was
pretty stunning the director of the fbi
in charge of one of the most high
profile investigations
in the history the fbi said if he knew
then what he knows now
he would not sign the warrant
application against carter page
this is a big day for carter page i
think he's going to become a rich man he
deserves to be compensated
so what happened here is that the
democratic party
hired a foreign agent christopher steele
who enlisted a suspected russian spy
to create a dossier that was a bunch of
garbage
russian disinformation and the fbi
bought it hook line and sinker
used it four times against an american
citizen a trump campaign person
to get a warrant if that doesn't bother
america then something's wrong
to my democratic colleagues if the
shooter on the other foot should be
burning the place down
so every single person that that
told that warned about that dossier
right to now
what did they tell comey when did they
tell comey i think you need to
cross check everything comey has said
prior i would expect you'll see
inconsistencies i got